this is the destiny to collector's
edition this is the Xbox version and
I've been playing all week and I've been
having so much fun I absolutely love
destiny one my sister and I we played
that so much we would get into arguments
as to who was gonna go and get the door
to get the food because if we didn't eat
we couldn't survive and then if we
didn't eat it survive in real life how
are we gonna survive in the game you
don't so today we're unboxing the
collector's edition a lot of people were
asking me what I was gonna be playing on
I chose to play destiny 2 on Xbox one
because that's where my friends are
playing I did play the beta on
PlayStation my final decision was Xbox
so right now I'm sorry
oh gosh I've lost track of painful to
you but that hurt really bad let's open
up this beast of a box ever close I'm
shot over here but it's so zoomed in but
even if I open this again pal oh okay so
here's inside the box we've got our game
here I believe this is we'll find out a
second when I set this off to the side
so I can give you guys some close-up
stuff over here
first things first here's our game which
comes in this really nice little
metallic case open this up take a look
nothing too crazy in here we've we've
got the disc what's this the USB cable
this is our cobalt themed collector's
box let's see what's inside we've got a
lot of things in here
hello is your where I would put this
eggs up in my office the winner should
be a football schematic these are the
military pawns
[Music]
we've also got some stickers here this
is the Cabal booklet do you desire
eternal greatness
do you seek true freedom i unknown hold
the power to grant you these gifts well
this looks like some light reading
material from my next flight this is
super cool I already know what this is
because I read it on the back of the box
this is solar panel USB charger and lie
on battery with built-in light it's
that's what it says here we have our
solar panel I've got two of them on both
sides here right here we have our on
button and here's the switch so we can
go from solar to USB
we've also got this this is our little
flashlight how do I turn the flashlight
on oh this has two different lighting
features it has the diffuse and the
spotlight
if you spot something quickly honestly
you I have an emergency to go hit that I
have in case of an emergency or a
disaster so this is something that I'm
gonna be putting close to it because
having an option to have solar power if
you're in the middle of nowhere granted
this may take a very long time to charge
but it's better than nothing and I don't
have a solar charge or anything so this
is pretty neat this is what we came for
so I saw Lamarr did an unboxing of his
destiny to collector's edition and I was
freaking out because this bag is
incredible you guys are new here one of
the things that I love our backpacks and
bags I'm always looking for ways to
store things and this looks so cool
oh and the quality is way better than I
find this looks really good you could
also wear it as a backpack are you
kidding me to the wall and it's very
tight squeeze not like my pack on do I
look good
well I'd like to know is how many kids
are gonna use this as their
back-to-school backpack this can be nice
to put a tripod on you're supposed to
put here a little charger in here like
this to carry it which is also pretty
thick let's give you my mule to go
emergency bags and very excited about
this always close your knives when
you're not using them let's take a
really good look at this bag so they
have all these different little flaps
here this is magnetic so it just kind of
sticks down incredible detail this is
just button down here oh this has like a
little zipper here too look at this put
some extra batteries in there this could
be a nice place to put your phone this
could be a nice place to put your knife
this is a nice place that you can put
some coins or SD cards another little
eye pop here as well inside there's also
a bunch of little areas here to put
things definitely to front to your bag
let's talk about it this is awesome
there's three different ways that you
can wear this bag there's a backpack a
version a messenger bag version and a
sling bag these also can be removed too
so if you don't want to have these on
top of here those can come off this is
so customizable these all pop off so you
can basically wear this however you
wanna wear it
here's the messenger style you guys
already saw the backpack oh yes oh yes I
fashioned I don't have enough room to
model it for you but you get the point
okay that is that's makes you
collector's edition that's everything
that's in the box I'm curious to see if
you guys are playing destiny are you
waiting until the holidays to play I
know a lot of you guys are back to
school which is the most difficult thing
ever I remember those days where it's
like summer's over
games are all starting to come out now
in the fall and you're in school and
you're like I just want to be home
playing games but I'm not it gets better
guys because when you're an adult you
can willfully neglect your
responsibilities but then you're
responsible for your actions so if you
take off too much work you're probably
gonna get fired or if you play too much
video games and you neglect your YouTube
channel you're also gonna be fired by
your viewers I just why I started a
gaming channel to begin with because I
was playing so many games and I was
completely avoiding my actual main
channel on YouTube so well this'll work
out great I will start a gaming channel
I could play my games and then post that
but then it was just so time consuming
and then I wasn't enjoying playing the
games for entertainment I was more
playing the games to entertain you guys
and I wasn't enjoying playing them
anymore so once I stopped doing that I'm
back I love it
I'm enjoying playing in my free time why
should show you guys my gaming setup I
might have showed you my vlog but I will
show you here right now here's the
gaming setup this is my station
this is jeanna station Jenna's Xbox is
connected to this guy right here it's my
xbox 1s connected to here and this is
where we sit and play so now I'll show
you guys but level I'm currently at I
just hit level 20 Oh
glands seasons yes so there's my girl
and 196 power
there's my gear I've yet to get an
exotic but I'm trying that's it guys I
will see you in my next video if you
guys are playing destiny let me know who
you were playing as I'm gonna go edit
this video and then go back to playing
destiny
[Music]